it's like i'm making burger soup over
here
that's the way they do it though
my george his name oates my name is
george most and it's
my job to take what's up here and
download it for you
all that burger intel kicking around in
this
big brand of mine not that big it's a
normal sized brain but it's full of
burger knowledge and pretty much nothing
else
i got a lot of it last season you
learned all about the loco moco one of
hawaii's great
regional traditions but guess what
hawaii actually has
more than one regional specialty they
also have something called the teriyaki
burger
this burger is delicious it is
absolutely delicious hawaii has these
great casual eating spots that are kind
of like american diners
where they serve things like the loco
moco spam
soup great like comfort food classics of
hawaii and that's where you're going to
find a teriyaki burger the teriyaki
burger's actually not even called a
teriyaki burger in hawaii if you're
looking for a taranaki burger you have
to ask for a barbecue burger
[Music]
that was good right depending on where
you are in hawaii some people will
actually use
teriyaki sauce as a condiment on top or
they'll marinate the burger in teriyaki
sauce and then cook it that way so it
gets nice and sticky sweet
i think the best method is to use both
to actually
cook a marinated burger on a flat top
and then
put teriyaki sauce on top of it pow pow
let's make a burger okay first one of
the the one of the things that they
didn't do in hawaii for sure is that
just a thin patty it's very thin padding
what i'm going to do
i'm going to use a patty press which i
wouldn't normally do
but you take fresh meat i'll get it
right again look at that don't do that
take fresh meat
and press that's it then patty
see that right on the ground that's it
also i made a i made all my own teriyaki
sauces and marinades
that's good that's really good you could
put this on cardboard if it tastes great
i
it mean soy sauce something called mirin
basic cooking wine
that's made in japan brown sugar some
garlic and some
ginger and corn starch to make it thick
i also made my own teriyaki marinade
which is basically just this with some
water in it
teriyaki actually means in japanese
terry
to glaze and yaki to cook so it's glaze
cooking basically it's cooking with
with sugar so i have a cook burger patty
right
and that's going to go right into the
marinade there you go
bath time take a little bath little
burger it's bath time
oh yeah okay
first things first mayo this is probably
the greatest known brand obviously in
japanese mayonnaise cupi
the reason that japanese mayo is so good
is because unlike us mayo which is also
fantastic by the way us mayo is
fantastic most mayo is i mean
to me i think mayonnaise is one of the
the greatest inventions of all time
seriously
one of the other the hamburger clearly
japanese mayonnaise is different than
other males because
they don't use the whole egg they use
only the yolk which makes it
obviously very yellow and very creamy
get out there yeah
buddy some chopped onion on the bottom
for flavor and crunch iceberg lettuce
so these burgers have been luxuriating
in this this marinade over here on the
griddle
and i'm gonna put one of these cooked
marinated burgers back
yeah buddy first time i went to hawaii i
went to the wnm and it was like 10
o'clock in the morning for a burger
i got off the plane and i was so
jet-lagged and so like jet lag stoned
that i left my guitar on the plane
and went and got a burger and i
didn't see the guitar until i got home
they actually set the thing home
i was in a band this hair was in a band
once back in the 90s
i thought i was a rock star now it is
now i just flip burgers
i was in a band called toss and we
actually we had an umlaut over the o so
technically we were pronounced tuss
that girl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey look it's signed by lou reed the
read signed by guitar see that
okay so the burger comes off the sugars
have caramelized down there perfectly
i'm gonna put this on top of my dope bun
now the most important
part the teriyaki sauce goes on top
look at that oh my god
and this course would not be complete
without yet another
squirt of japanese mayonnaise on top of
that
buttered toasted bun
look at that thing this is a teriyaki
burger
what are they calling hawaii a barbecue
burger
i'm hungry i'm eating
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
take it eat it so good
fish it's good right all right one bite
um i've had a lot of great jobs in my
life some of my favorites were
being in a band for sure um being a
lifeguard being a radio dj
the greatest jobs in the world uh but i
wouldn't change the thing
i love being america's hamburger expert
i got a lot of stuff up here
it's coming out it's just it's oozing
out for you
that's disgusting sorry i didn't say
that
hmm i'll see you next time
make something else fun